o la crisis en haití ha alimentado el
tráfico ilegal de personas la mayoría de
los migrantes haitianos que ingresan a
latinoamérica lo hacen por brásil pasan
por perú y luego llegan a ecuador ciento
se esperan allí para cruzar hacia
colombia y continuar su camino hacia el
norte tras llegar a panamá siguen por
centroamérica hasta llegar a mexico para
más adelante pisar el anhelado suelo
estadounidense toda una travesía en
busca de un mejor futuro en medio de una
crisis económica agravada por la
pandemia
las autoridades ecuatorianas calculan
que desde junio entre 450 y 650
haitianos transitan diariamente por la
terminal de autobuses ecuatoriana
estamos armando dispositivos de
seguridad en diferentes puntos
fronterizos especialmente los informales
lamentablemente son utilizados por gente
inescrupulosa
que engaña a ciudadanos extranjeros en
la frontera entre ecuador y perú existen
más de 20 pasos fronterizos irregulares
actualmente en el país tenemos alrededor
de 350 y tramos ese es el número
sin embargo tenemos también esta
situación de ingreso por frontera y de
manera irregular al país los migrantes
pagan desde 15 hasta 30 dólares por ser
transportados a este piales en colombia
desde donde siguen su camino hacia el
norte